we have one councillor Williams any
other apologies now I move that apology
seconded
counselor at concern all those in favor
that we accept cuts are Williams
apologies say aye
against declare it carried item to
conflicts of interest in e2 minute no
all right we move on to item 3 which is
the confirmation of minutes from our
February the 13th meeting which is pages
5 to 9 in your agenda Thank You
counselor a seconder councillor Blakey
any any alterations or anything
I noticed that we've got a feast board
and on page three and five instead of a
health spa
[Music]
yeah all right old one I'll put those
minutes all those in favor that the
minutes of February the 13th Chernykh
record of that meeting we say against a
clear carriage item for matters arising
now I was
why is it going to be the there's an
item I'll receive an item in the zone
the zone program item 6.2 design
programs gotcha got what we were going
with was it so we'll wait till then you
need any other medicine I've got one
here about we talked about going out to
have a look at the Burgess stream
project and I just raised that it's been
it got funding on Monday from the zone
committee through immediate steps so at
some point
can someone note that it would probably
be this this committee is keen to go and
have a look and I think it probably
would be good to extend their invite to
the zone committee members who might
like to to attend as well it may be that
it's not too you know October or
something that'll be good any other
horizon no okay thank you
and so we moved to item 5 which is
deputations and invite andrew apps from
he came to take us through whatever he's
going to take us through thank you
Andrew
okay so you said an update on I'll call
it covert end all things around covert
funding the degree of understanding that
we have there's just really three slides
today the first one sort of looking at
it and the big picture bringing it to
what government can re down and then
bring it down into the Waimakariri level
so these are there's that list there is
a list of the various funds that are are
available at the moment from from
central government our main focus is on
the seeker Monday on the regional
environmental projects and let's have
say also we've been doing some work with
billion trees and the provincial growth
fund so those are the three that I'll
cover off now that regional sector was
actually asked by central government to
respond and for the emitter to to do so
at pace it's about 48 hours to bring
together a whole programme of work we've
been to through two rounds of that the
second one sort of qualifying and
providing a little bit more information
truant has been involved in that and
then we've also have calls drawn on the
knowledge that we have of what was
actually going on and the zones and
possible projects in terms of bringing
the various programs that we would apply
for for funds for the we're expecting
answers back by the way on this probably
within the next week or two as we
progress through so when we've looked at
it the program that we put forward as
we're looking at a total of 72 million
dollars over five years the ones
highlighted in green are the ones that
in particular effect Waimakariri so the
planting and regeneration program I'm
just going to stop before I talk too
much about that aspect and jump into
another working group that's actually
occurring within Environment Canterbury
at the moment which currently is made of
counselors and staff that will be
expanded to include other other
stakeholders and it's around a word
program for region Aboriginal planting
and regeneration program the working
title is called red and black and green
and we're looking at all things to do
with what would it take to really
upscale a planting and regeneration
program so when I say planning and
regeneration that's everything from the
obvious planting but right through to
protection and everything sort of in
between and what focus would that
particular program have whether it be
for example lowland streams or would it
be broader than that so those things are
sort of being worked through at the
moment and when that gets to a stage
where there's a at least a framework
around at least men will start sharing
with the stakeholders of which obviously
the District Council's
part of that the Regional Planning
program there that we put up effectively
that would put that red and black cream
Britain black and green program on
steroids that's talking about for that
particular one we're looking at seven
million dollars per annum now to put
that in perspective that's when we look
at the work we've done under the likes
of immediate steps programs in planting
and regeneration space so this is
excluding things like braided rivers and
all of that it's basically saying we're
going to do the same every year as what
we've done for the last ten years for
the next five years so that's for the
next five years to really upscale things
the planting program and I'm jumping
around a bit here the red and black and
green planting program that's being
looked at as a sort of 15 to 20 year
program a little bit like the taranaki
one so this is two streams of
complementary work going on but the
attraction of this one is obviously that
that's got a very large pot of money
with it braided river revival program
braided river revival is a program which
has is led by the votes led by the
bellies of hanger chi recreation and
conservation and if you like it's a
non-statutory program but we are
expanding it to look at river works and
everything like that so that work there
in the case of this the HD recovery has
already been identified as the first of
the braided river braided rivers that we
were putting this project wrapping it
around and there's quite a bit of work
already being identified for that that
would extend to the likes of the Waimea
career II and other braided rivers would
just simply allow us to do the work that
we want and needs to be done a whole lot
faster
the next one down and green is around
the the regional parks and looking at
expanding those ends there's a few other
spots around where regional parks could
be created some of the it's actually
quite so we say straightforward work in
terms of making better areas but it's
also about creating things like a
whitewater park that happens to be in
the cell one side of the waymaker Erie
but we are looking at other
opportunities too so that they the the
likes of the Roma career a regional park
and the Ashley Rico hurry Regional Park
which by default also doubles up in the
braided river revival to those two that
they get enhanced through that and then
another one is around regional catchment
management so we absolutely understand
that this catchment man has been in
catch when groups needs to be lead from
the ground up but we want to be in a
position to really support these groups
and we're saying well it's a deadly
divide 12 and actually start working
with them and help whether it be with
funding or other mechanisms that we can
provide to them help them be successful
but obviously our role and they're often
as at least the third or fourth seat
back and the bus is not driving the bus
off of that one
there's a couple of things there where
we have been successful there for laters
next generation farmers they've just
been awarded a sum of funds for the next
three years so this from a initiative
people working with them on and also for
that matter here in a retrial and being
here group day two progressing quite a
wellness look like they'll get a
significant amount of funds so yeah
[Music]
and in okay so one thing to be very
clear is these funding funding from the
Coburn schemes and similar they
definitely will come with conditions
obviously those conditions of the one
that's going to be in the big time will
be around employment some of the funds
make a big sure you've spelt it out this
means do not use volunteers it's about
using creating jobs and all the projects
that you folks have got on the go for
the list that was provided to me of the
that when we've discussed around the the
green spaces lists in a recent list that
Sophie had circulated around
opportunities in the coastal area it's
definitely in the mix but nothing's
guaranteed for funding because we simply
are this is all working at pace some of
the information is a bit gray but we're
starting to Ford you here but we are
feeling pretty confident that funding
will come through in one form or another
we have been working with dock and in as
you've just said be aware as things get
a little bit clearer with with funds
then we can produce further with
stakeholders including the Runanga and
obviously the the tight team of
Environment Canterbury and the District
Council will work together on that and
to a degree there and down the bottom
have got hold on for the ride
if these funds come through it is a lot
of money it's way beyond what we've been
doing in the past so that kana as it has
is exciting element to it but it also
has a scary part to it in terms of
making it work and and doing it and
coordinated approach and we are very
aware that it cannot be achieved with
just environment can to be doing it will
be spreading their network to a making
sure that things are leveraged and and
delivered well any questions
injury just just in terms of what's
happening behind the scenes what's
happening with working with agencies so
that they know this is backed up by a
social enterprise or employment agencies
all of those people what's the one we
know that's out there or what do we not
know so that if this does hit the ground
what's happening in that space right now
we we don't there may be others of
environment can it be there no but as
the bro LARPing plays be more about
identifying the projects and bringing
them together I know that that had been
we can get some feedback to you on that
but I definitely see a there may be a
role we are you know we look at some of
these projects and I don't know of all
of this happening and in Waimakariri but
I think of the folk of Bunnings and
connecting those two quite quickly would
be yeah in official maybe so nibble is
we can certainly it's a top priority
within the program as the employment of
people so we can take that one because I
think it's a good example where we know
there's a pool of people and we know
these jobs that maybe that's the one
that we try and see how do we work that
through to to join to securely join the
dots yeah yeah
so--but definitely be there in mind yeah
realistically looking
available how much time does that allow
for employment in terms of a time frame
have you looked at any of that is it a
one-year program or two-year program
some of the projects are talking about
it different they are they range from
let's get underway within two months
right through to end the funding goes
out to fight the covert funding goes out
for five years we are hoping that
programs like the red and black and
green that gets something going and then
going beyond that that includes we are
obviously looking at and they in that
instance looking at the supply of stock
as well as always for planting programs
is an issue and some of them in the
space of the provincial growth fund they
want things underway within a matter of
weeks yeah so you've got to yeah and and
and those part of it doesn't necessarily
mean people working but it's the plans
and things in place so that's when they
say shovel-ready we've got a good idea
in a concept but I'll just very briefly
talking to Sophie before the coastal
stuff she talked about its would should
we say working it up a little bit so
you've actually got a at least something
to sell to them and probably sell that
as a cluster of work a number of a
number of wetlands down you mentioned
sourcing the plants for the planting
have you actually spoken to any
suppliers about possible needs going
forward if you're successful we we have
that we
step back from that first Sandra you may
recall that Jason that did some work
around what's effectively its echo
sourcing but about the different plight
of plants to be being planted in the
different areas of Waimakariri and then
also you've got the various situations
there with it being wetland lowland
stream etc so that sort of matrix so
we're making up we're working refreshing
our lists of saying these are the right
plants for my mercury and at the moment
we're actually going through the list
excuse me to go right here's a core
range of product of plants that might
need up to 100 different varieties he's
a cool range of 20 or 15 that'll make up
the bulk of it
give them weird that most of the work
will do so we're getting that clear
before we go to to the the nurseries
that said the council has all over to
divide some funding in this year to go
towards just initiating that order
because a big part of this is about and
the role that pets environment cannery
can play as an abling the industry to
actually and a lot of that's actually
about providing funds so they can do
their work see collection right there
and then for then for next year the
council has put food about 250,000 for
this project
that's less than pepper we wanted but
it's it's a start
better they're more looking towards the
the long term plan but again if the
covert funding comes along then its
financials should actually be an honor
sure it'll be how quickly we can get
production underway yeah
yeah we have we have spoken to them
informally but we can't say anything
until we've actually just a few things
we just need to get so yeah then for
more discussions you is there any areas
that are identified in any of these
projects that don't actually need
remnant plants that you can actually
source from area some of the projects
will infect us be fencing projects for
regeneration and they can still so the
fencing is the labor and that's where
the jobs are so there's some of those
there is stock available now so it's a
bit of a mix and part of what we're
looking at as the projects going
actually given that moat I think people
now understand that planting is at least
a three year program for any significant
site and so we would look more to if
plants aren't available people more
looking at the first year will be site
preparation and fencing and all that and
getting everything ready for the second
year of planting have an answer sorry
question I'm asking is there any other
sites that don't need remnant planting
because surely not every site or every
piece of ground has to heaven ring plan
we must must be able to plant new plants
different plants English glance what
either in some areas for some purposes
okay when it comes to environment
cannery up until now it's bad been in in
about indigenous biodiversity exotics is
being considered as part of written
vetting green as part of the mix in
order to get so we say that the buy-in
to the wider community because initially
discussions have been about I'll work
with the willing but the willing is a
selective group under and I'm going to
put too much of a tight piece around it
part of the program is actually about
extending the participation to actually
bring more people into it and order to
do that sometimes you start to make a
bit of a mix some of the some of it and
North Canterbury has been around using
poplar and Willow but that's also to do
with some soil erosion
work up there as well yep thank you it
does yep yep and we relatively we won't
bother white will come through crystal
we will just let you know as soon as we
s be here Thanks
okay thank you
we're back on I will move on now to the
reports and item 6.1 wishes are hard
here to our working group terms of
reference and invite some grant and Kate
to take us through this over to you our
pages 10 to 25 thank you oh thanks
Sandra good morning everybody
so the report is to run through the
terms of reference and also the sitting
up of a working group which would look
at what the HR work plan an action plan
would be to come out of that so the
report that's in front of you you'll see
there that it's actually proposing a max
of who would be approved for the group
so you'll see there that we've got the
biodiversity portfolio holder councillor
Stewart on there and then there's a mix
of staff and also another elected member
of point II that is being requested so
we're asking that the land and waterway
committee makes a nomination for who
that might be so that we can appoint
someone today group the terms of
reference you will see in the appendix
there that's set out the purpose of what
the group's about the quorum and also
some of the objectives which were taken
from the original report that came
through late last year and it's kind of
formalized what that would be the idea
would be that the working group then
sends back a work plan to the land and
waterway committee so that they can
understand exactly what it is that that
looks like and there can be some
recommendations made around that as well
it's worth noting that obviously with an
E annual plan there was an application
for a hundred thousand for the first
year of the project which is looking
primarily to implement some work around
the camp Kate's been doing some great
work there especially around mapping and
also getting an understanding for what
it is that we can actually do within
that space as well as more recently been
working on some cross sections as well
so that we could have a bit of a look
about what it might look like so that we
can bring that back to the to the group
as well and actually sort of show hey
this is this is actually what it looks
like on the ground this is how it could
work
some of the things that we need to do as
well around maybe easements and other
land tenure discussions that we might
need to have just to help create their
continual flow through there as well
so that's the report in a nutshell I'm
very happy to take any questions on that
as well or any reason why this group
can't be this committee nd keep the
quorum the same but they have the this
committee because I know the chair not
talked about another couple members that
we thinking probably necessary under the
and the directive here but there any
reason why I can't be this committee
with the same quorum that could have the
meetings before and after the meeting or
you know to feed into this committee
because i mean it's it's sexy the basis
of getting this committee to work it's
so i mean the information delivered to
the committee straight away in my view
is something that they need to be
participating and so i'm just that's my
question is there any reason why I
couldn't be this committee was I'm sorry
ribéry for media and threw it in the
grant but I think that's really your
decision
and the the purpose with this this
working group doesn't really have any
delegated authority it's more a group of
duis so you'll see it's predominantly
staff rather than elected members and
reports back into this committee for
decisions so the if it was to no oh.look
of course that's an option for you but
they caution I would have is that's not
necessarily quite the best forum for
just getting us you know I think the
bleeding staff staff to report some kind
of a project control structure that's a
reasonably limited number of people
where we can meet on a more ad hoc basis
and give a bit more day-to-day direction
I suppose it's not it's not a day-to-day
grow
but it's something that it's not quite
the full governance structure that this
committee is and in order I suppose I
would if if you were to say why can't
this committee do it then you'd almost
you could have one option is you don't
even have this working group you just
had been reporting directly to the
committee thus understood my question
really the structures fine but instead
of the one person actually have those
members of this committee appointed to
it now I mean if people don't just turn
up that's the your issue what I'm saying
is that you would I would think
generally I mean I just get around the
table people registering to each other
everybody wants to be honored for a
start and on just what I'm saying is
that your strategy is fine I've gotten
take no issue with you structure it's
about everybody working together to get
the means that you want to get okay I'm
sounds a little bit more like the solid
and hazardous waste working pony which
actually I know there's a lot of echt of
interest from elected members and
networks really well so it's a good
slightly less formal grouping so if you
were to you know here's a sentence up to
you and that would be is there any
reason why we couldn't just leave it is
this and you just invite all members of
the committee to attend if they wish but
they not be there easier way of managing
the group so that you've got a cool
decision making great but yeah this
members can contribute this what
speaking right
is more to questions what a lot of
people's view about the sort of
structure that councillor Atkinson's
talked about plus I've had an approach
from cheer of Runanga era paddle Rubin
and cheer of water zone Mike Blackwell
who are interested in being part of this
working group because you may be aware
that some of the water zone catchment
groups us as sort of well they're
talking about it but particularly if we
go to they came here there's a real
interest and lots of expertise in those
two people and I for one a really keen
that they are part of this working group
so there's that on the table as well so
certainly wasn't the intention to have
external parties as a member of us this
is really a staff the purpose of this is
really a staff working group to try and
make sure we've got some structure
around just managing their staff people
involved in feeding this committee and
in acting on decisions of this committee
so we I wouldn't recommend that you
invite others to attend this group will
certainly work with those other groups
and at a staff level but we we should
remember we do have the water zone
committee as well and which we're a
member of that includes a sort of a
wider group and I know we had a little
bit of this discussion even when the
land and water committee was being set
up and around the water zone it was
quite a lot of interest in it and we
almost had to say thank you for your
interest but this is a council committee
and I think again
that's the question that is probably
being tested here I think we've got a
lot of ways we've got like in terms of
the rune and we've got the reading
meetings we've also got the mahi tehy
committee we've got a lot of regular
staff interaction between council staff
and Environment Canterbury and I think
if we start to bring in too many moving
parts into this group and loses its
ability to function that effectively as
a staff working group I was just going
to say could we not just engage with
those external parties as needs be to
use to make use of their expertise and
their input without having them be a
formal part of the committee the best
steering group yes yes well they're
sitting an option and I'm not envisaging
ruining a rig I'm envisaging that year
in the - Cheers
because they have particular expertise
in some of the projects here so that's
the difference I'm not proposing opening
it to a ruining a rip or a water zone
members
I'm really sorry I've kind of try to
remember which question it was it was a
couple of questions ago it was effective
just so the question was just refresh my
memory cancel abandoned yes dear that's
certainly the intention that we will do
there and we already have got I believe
governance structures in place for that
for there to have been at a more formal
level but absolutely there is the
intention I absolutely recognize that
there is a huge amount of expertise to
be tapped into there particularly with
Maha Kai and just knowledge of the
camera ever so yeah that would be an
excellent outcome if we could make use
of that while we traverse through this
project I'm in your hands about how you
want to proceed here and there on the
table is one other elected member and if
if you want to go that way yep yes thank
you everything in there in the the
motion there is but just change the one
other elected member to councillor me
Lang's and add a note under D that notes
that all members of the lemon water
committee will be invited to attend the
meetings in have sneaking right and then
most the subsequent ones down if genie
in it you start from doing
the note given that it's a public
meeting in members of the committee can
the team at anytime any way do we need
do we need a note
just speaking to it very quickly and I
take any ribbons point that we all are
very very keen on this project would all
love to be involved and I certainly know
the community boards are also very keen
to have some input into this project
that's a very important one for our
district I think this is just to start
the process it's the strategy part of it
so really it just needs to be a small
group you can get the strategy started
and then that will diverge into
individual projects which is then when
we need all the expertise in industry so
just to get this moving I think it's
really good to have the five people
appointed I suggested council remainings
because of her connection with
sustainability and your other portfolios
I felt that would be an appropriate
person to be on there as well as
counselors should and I'm very very
hopeful that those snap couldn't move
this forward and bring us speak some
information on how we can get this
moving as quick as possible one question
I did want to ask staff as if there's
any way we can apply for funding for
this project through the covert 19 and
emergency jobs scheme if that's
something they could look into very
quickly would be very very helpful for
us because obviously funding is going to
be an ongoing battle with trying to keep
the rates down so I'm happy to support
the motion that's been put forward yeah
and look
tamo that we had Andrew here as well so
a few weeks ago we've actually been
doing a lot of work with Kate Sophie in
through Chris as well to get forward
some information to weekend about the
funds that they've been talking about
here one of the ones that we detailed
quite a lot to them was this project so
that they could actually understand
which they've picked up as well as to
how important that is for us in the
district as well so it's very much in
the mix therefore whatever comes out of
the Achaean process I can put the yes
you mean not being agents that the chair
of the water zone committee end the
chair of the Runanga as it so happens is
that you also become members of this
committee
the reason I've added this in is the
fact that in every point we get asked by
the very number Runanga in fact we don't
get asked if the hue we had told that
they are partners of Ayers in that they
wish to be in on the ground floor of
when we are developing these sorts of
projects policies all of those sorts of
things now we do have the Mojito here
committee and that's all good the
governance sort of that will come
through we're talking about a doing
party in the in the words of mr. Cleary
so they have asked many times to be on
the doing parties before we get to the
governance making parties if you like we
need to go and I think that's absolutely
important that that they are there on
the ground floor of this particular
project
I wouldn't recommend this to recommend
what I'm recommending to
a whole lot of other working parties but
this particular one we're talking about
land and water is absolutely goes to the
heart of the root of the Runanga and why
what it is that they're trying to get
through local government and what
they're trying to get through government
itself so I think that it's absolutely
necessary if indeed and I did that's why
I use part of if indeed they decline
that then that is fine you know but I
think we need to give the opportunity to
them to belong to this islet ground
roots in right on the floor and at the
beginning Thank You counselor and I just
take up my opportunity to talk to it as
well and I would agree I've had it
approaches from era Potter right at the
beginning about involvement and
[Music]
particularly on the doing and the
getting funding side as well I mean I've
got a couple of emails here about he
wants to apply for various funds I would
like to see that there the runing at
chair is involved from the outset and I
think it is very important that the
water zone chair is also involved we
need to spread the word and get
community by and and publicity for this
and I see that the Runanga is just out
there at the grassroots involvement
needs to be on board here without going
it is councillor Atkinson see it is a
separate step it is a separate step to
water zone it is a separate step to mate
are you or the ruining a monthly meeting
that you have this just brings everybody
in right at the the foundation of it out
so that they can go away and use their
networks and bring in it to me it it
concentrates and focuses right at the
grass level and I'm really keen that in
fact there is an invitation out to those
two people I'm not I'm making the
difference here and I see counts and
that's why I seconded at that and
we are talking about two particular
people who have particular expertise and
involvement here for the projects that
we're already talking about so I'm
really keen that if you don't want them
on a working group that they come in and
I can understand that that view but that
they are involved right at the start now
I'm quite happy that if this doesn't
work within 12 months that we have a
review of of it and just see whether it
is has focused and got us moving in the
way I'm I would expect it would have so
very happy to support that addition
pleasure my only downside I see is that
as Jared has said it's a it's a it's a
staff working committee bringing
Outsiders in like that it's going to run
immediately into timetabling problems
I'd imagine but basically that's their
fault if they can't fit in and they
can't doing that will so be it apart
from that I'm quite happy to have those
closer to thank you look just firstly
spire start by saying councillor Stewart
thank you for your patient and
enthusiasm in this area you've certainly
done a lot of work and the space
supported by the council as well and our
staff but I think I'm piercing your
leadership in this area I'd I would like
to acknowledge that I think the working
party in general is one where I think in
the space that we do need to show some
leadership so I'm very supportive of it
in in terms of extending it - I know mr.
curious and weeds here but I'm being
persuaded listening to the argument that
I an invitation to both the chair of the
water zone and also the chair of Nigeria
Hariri probably worth a lot of value and
if we are to make gains in this space we
need us broader by and as possible so
I'm relaxed and that's this the space
because we're shown that through the
water zone committee that works with all
parties coming together so in this space
I'm under the support and on balance I
note that concerns were raised but they
will be as councillor it consume each
end and has moving comments that
ultimately it's up to them particular
individuals as to whether or not they
wish to be here so that's fine in terms
of funding it was mentioned before just
like to mention that I hit a hit an
email you said Oh from the PG if funders
so I will seem that to respective staff
members so that we can look at
opportunities in their space during you
might want to just eat it for a list I
understand there was a dirt and Chris
are putting together a list of all the
various funds that there are to make
sure that we are we are connected that
we've got applications and then there's
a process underway because there's a lot
of funds being announced at the moment
that's just making sure that we're on
top of all those and giving our
applications and but no I'm on balance
I'm gonna support this thank you
oh I've just got a question on working
group vision on page 15 now I'm fully
across this and I just wondered anyone
who who reads it for the first time
where we say to improve ecological and
recreational and recreation Nicholas
along and districts waterways to create
and health healthy ecosystems and a
community of Guardians that's excellent
part and parcel of our hearty to our is
rehabilitation of the waterway so I
wondered and is that clear to people
reading that because I was the question
because I was going to suggest that will
create healthy aquatic and terrestrial
ecosystems in a community of Guardians
just to make it clear to those who are
reading it that in fact the waterway
rehabilitation is part and parcel fact
the fundamental step of going forward
with this project now just tell me
whether you knew all knew that and
everybody would understand that when
they read it as written
to it as a slight change to the terms of
reference
if we speak could I just ask that
because we haven't hit staff comment on
that proposal could I just last year if
pieces that proposal the put them in
that proposal bill wick of all and what
we're trying to do yes there is workable
that's perfectly fine
b5 are we still on as written near one
elected member pointy with it with the
automatic assumption that any member of
this committee can attend if they chose
to is that was it we were up to was
notes that says 'yes described counselor
mailings and then notes all members of
the land and water working group
involved that what there is the motion
that's currently on the table I'm quite
happy to to move a to H with those
various I will put it thank you
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the claret carries thank you we
move on to item six point two which is
the zone implementation program for 2021
and invite Sophie Elam to the table in
your hand Sophie Thank You Dakota right
this is the report for information with
the purpose of outlining projects for
the 2020 21 financial year and there
have been some changes to the zone
implementation program addendum was of a
budget due to the covert revaluation of
the annual plans so the capex budget was
cut from a hundred thousand to fifty
thousand for next year and then the
operational budget has slight reduction
of the stormwater education funds suite
from 20,000 to ten thousand so not a
huge change in the operational the only
other projects we've retained
just before I go into the the the
project so next year we do have some
delays as well from covert for a
particular our planting projects that
were due to happen autumn
some work for community groups for
example and what's happened post covert
is there were the contractors that we
would normally have carryout plantings
are very busy trying to catch up and
because we didn't book contractors in
for the community plantings will
probably will be looking at they carry
over quests for those plantings yeah so
the pickax projects we have the main the
biggest one there is the biodiversity
and immunity projects that we started
off this year in the South Brook at
Townsend fields and the Cherokee stream
reserve my cuckoo so we've had some good
progress there with some plantings in
the spring last year at South Brook and
we've also had a path put in there's a
photo in the report at teriyaki you
stream Reserve which allows us so it
axis wasn't issued the air to get a get
through there were some culverts put in
as well so we gotta get to the whole
section of the reserve and now planting
us can carry on along carry out along
the whole the whole reserve reserve
quite a significant planting plan for
next year we have tidal plantings in the
kuiper river which were meant to happen
and this this summer actually but due to
a high demand of the wetland plants from
an ek and order the nursery accident you
made a mistake and didn't have the stock
to provide and then obviously with Cove
above here to postpone until next summer
and we finally have for the epics
projects in their spawning habitat
improvements in the Taranaki stream
Courtney and McIntosh drain so those are
continuing on so we have had Willow
removal pentas removals a tree removal
which was shading the younger grasses
where they spawn and we have a planting
happening in June for the Courtney so
that will that can take place moving on
to the optics projects for next year we
have a pilot looking at shading of
drains to try and reduce the amount of
maintenance we are the clearing of the
water weeds that
we'll be there was there was me to
convince this year but it's probably
gonna be moved into well will be moved
into next year and maybe the year after
I would have the drainage review which I
believe came to land and water committee
so that is the drainage review looked at
how we count how w DC carries out our
drainage practices and is has been
morphed into a drainage management plan
that will go to Environment Canterbury
to apply for our consent for maintenance
in mine works in waterways a stormwater
education program should hopefully it
wasn't ended to kick off this school
year but obviously due to covered that
we're looking at starting that next
school year to be confirmed we have a
research project which we have
negotiated with the University of
Canterbury to look it so it's a partial
funding for a PhD in to climate change
and the effect on indigenous
biodiversity in waterways with our
district as one of the key modeling and
sample sites so looking at how fish for
a debt to to climate change in what we
can do to try to accommodate that you
could receive a support so helping us to
get the information we need to make good
decisions this MOOC funding for that
next year the Christian counselor
Barnett heard about the nitrate study
pilots that will be repeated next year
with hopefully the same wells so we can
start looking at trend over time and
finally there's a small amount next year
for developing technical guidance for
private wells so this is a project that
started this year we have a draft in
progress and we are doing some mapping
of manganese iron arsenic and nitrate
for our districts that will be part of a
brochure for people with private wells
or looking at putting down a potential
new well that they can get information
about what might be some things to watch
out for so I have to take questions a
minute you just
question two well probably Tajiri is
some Macintoshes dryden given the OTP
and given the changes that could come
through then you send in through the
airspace the direction in which we're
going Macintoshes drain in filled with
drain could be affected by that we're
looking at planting it up depending on
the scheme the stormwater scheme that
happens with the with the nephron II and
development down there is it wise to be
spending some of this money on
mcintoshes drain if indeed in I mean it
is a bit of crystal ball gazing but is
it wise to be spending money on that
enhancing it if indeed it could be
changed in the near future near being
you know genius 15 years but yeah Ellie
are you more familiar with a specific
detail of just speaking on that brochure
that you referred to with the wells and
will that be actively distributed or
will it be in it in that targeted way or
will it just be passively there for
people to pick up for information
because I think that would be really
good for well holders to have in front
of them because they often don't think
about testing their wells you're so
differently active distribution we are
looking at both online 24 mats and in a
physical brochure and we also plan to
work with Environment Canterbury to
expand to a brochure for different
districts there are the other district
councils might try and copy our example
is the discussion we're having at the
country drinking what a reference group
so we might be leaving the way on having
something standard that is for all of
Canterbury then Environment Canterbury
grandma scientists work with us to
develop a and also have the individual
local council components just two
questions Sophia the work that you're
doing to do to look at testing of and
different elements in our water is that
being feedback into the district plan
review to look at areas of zoning that
might be appropriate given the state of
private water wells so far we have in
any overlay discussions within the
district plan there are no particular
zones that I would say I consistently
above the mavs for drinking water
standards it's more I think that what
the maps will show that we're getting
developed is that it is patchy and you
do need to have there's no consistency
it's a lot of variation even from one
well to the next nextdoor well so having
the understanding perhaps our overlay or
an area where you say this is not we
usually have a well is probably not the
way to go it's it's just having that
expectation that if you drill a well
there is a risk and you should get it
tested regularly to to make sure you
know what's going on and the second one
is about the shading trials we've hit
reports on that for many years of
different of the trials and it talks
about a continuation will you be
bringing back the results because it's
been ongoing for a long time are we
going to see some more results about how
that's been working so yeah this is a
slightly different but a piece of work
to the work that Greg Bennett has done
in the past I think although all the
work from Carrick's it might have been
as well yes so this is this is a
different section of different different
sites they were looking at it planting
up so I've do believe Carrick's has very
reported back on on that shading but
maybe not too directly to this council
so that's for me an issue for me to to
rectify so what I should probably is the
word trial but actually it's a pilot
where we just expanding number of areas
that we hear shaving yeah yeah I used
the wrong word yeah yeah sorry it's it's
a
proven concept yeah exactly I've called
it a pilot I think in the in the wrong
gourd weird choice yeah
from
a 2d a seconder
now councillor Atkinson thank you yes a
a good program ahead I think that
hopefully we get will use all our budget
I'll be urging that we do in fact carry
out some every single item on both their
capex and OPEX yes nothing through the
realtor to add our one question that the
the work that we are doing on the South
Brook have we done macro invertebrate
index before we started doing this all
these sorts of works so that we can
actually measure whether the
enhancements are having an effect
no we w DC hasn't I believe there might
be some sampling information already I
couldn't look into you know it would be
good to get something there as soon as
possible before yeah so it could be that
we we do in to take some sampling
ourselves
I just like to just echo what you've
just said about establishing a baseline
I think that would be a great step to
take and I don't think it would be that
difficult with it really and and it
would show a noticeable improvement or
if what we're doing isn't working but
certainly gives us something to put
forward for to show our efforts are
getting somewhere so yeah I support that
absolutely yep thank you all right and
I'll I'll put the recommendation and all
those in favor please say aye
against the current carries thank you
and we move on to item six point three
which is the camera enhancement fund in
the Copper River rehabilitation projects
an update in welcome Janet Fraser to
take us through all this thank you you
know I'll start off yeah so this report
is also report for information mainly
because you might remember it the secret
of June council meeting the terms of
reference that were approved for this
committee to take on the role of the
camera our enhancement fund subcommittee
in the kuiper rehabilitation working
party so this is a bit of a background
of where the what's happened with these
projects and and programs in the past
and we were going in the future
and maybe a bit of a heads up with some
of the the things that might be a few
challenges or opportunities so we had
some photos in the I believe oh no yes
we do we have the photos of the two
heavy sediment traps and the reports
that were installed for the last few
years we had some bank stabilization
works at Northbrook so this is with a
camera for enhancement fund what we have
had problems with those we are waiting
collect global consent for the
maintenance and minor works and
waterways to undertake the majority of
the works and it has been something it
has been delayed unfortunately due to
that need to have a drain management
plan so it almost the
it but uh we're still not sure quite
when that consent will come through
we've also undertaken at the chi in the
keio a river i'm intertidal planting
there's a photo of the what they're
planting looks like and the report and
dredging works which generalize a lot
more about than me so met with some
christians the in the future as an
exponential year we are looking at
sediment traps for the camer enhancement
fund work more planting drainage
wetlands and yes it's probably it's good
summary so that is not just next
financial year but ongoing will probably
take a couple of at least a couple of
years for the program of works to be
completed and yeah i just mentioned it's
consent dependent for their kayakoy or
rehabilitation projects continuation the
dredging that's just about to start his
has started on the chi boy river
planting both the terrestrial plant
along the highway riverbanks within the
stock banks and more of the intertidal
planting in the water and i was just a
small era in the table one just below
point six point two point one i had a
fund of twenty thousand a bunch of
twenty thousand for planting and fencing
that was in create he's actually thirty
thousand so the total the table should
be ten thousand more which takes it more
in line with i pretty much a match of
how much funny the money there was to
allocate so maybe that could be noted in
there in the minutes for correction and
also the small at the time when i put
this report together i didn't know for
sure whether the planting would be
postponed we were still trial look for
contractors so there's the terrestrial
planting for the chem for the cowboy
river that will be a late carryover
request as we haven't had any luck
securing a contractor
he'd get it um there was some
match-funding from he came in this
planting that $10,000 a year I think it
was is this ongoing and if so will the
transfer through to the other program of
works that you've in the last item that
you add from weekend I mean they're
usually very generous when it comes to
the sort of stuff I just wondered with
it so environment came to Bri the pack
Ranger head the kick started the
terrestrial planting last year was the
five planting nodes between the camera
the mouth down to the William Street
Bridge and they have had some planting
that you'll see just upstream of the
William Street bridge on the northern
bank which where we are our proposed to
issue your planting was to augment and
continue and then they have some
planting nodes on the south bank
downstream of the Cure boating club to
the Courtney Stream confluence so
they've finished that last year so this
financial year they had the willow
control so right through the main stem
and you'll see some gaps I think now in
the willows downstream of the fishing
corner in particular so our terrestrial
planting now is intended to help reduce
wave Lake Erie ocean and those areas so
we haven't sought any further weaken
funding contribution because we're
relying on them to continue to undertake
the below control between the main stem
and there would be an argument to push
harder for he can to be more proactive
in their maintenance of removing ivy and
controlling willows with the ongoing
saline intrusion it might be a comment
for I'm Chris Brown with budget for
maintenance inside the stop banks Sandra
and I had a meeting last Friday I think
it was with friend from Environment
Canterbury and he's the new river
engineer there and we talked about that
willow control specifically especially
in that highway main town center area
where the river as their end
he was reasonably
sold on the idea of giving us more
information around when he was going to
be doing maintenance how he was going to
be doing maintenance and working with us
a bit more proactively than we've had in
the past around what trees we're going
to remove when we're going to remove
them suggesting a walk around that we do
on a yearly basis to issue identify the
trees which need to be removed so that
we can budget accordingly for any
backfilling of terrestrial marketing
that we actually do so that was a really
successful meeting which I think we're
going to get some good information
hopefully around budgets and actually
Ford program for willow Control which we
haven't had in the past has been quite
hard to get of course
linking that end with the presentation
there Andrew Arps justed if we suddenly
have 7 million dollars a year for the
next 5 years of planting along the side
of streams and rivers in our district
then I think fundings not going to be an
issue for terrestrial plants on Copper
River
and on page 40
talk about hypo river rehabilitation and
we have the very sobering phrase about
the river at the boat ramp testing as
the worst freshwater psyche monitored on
Canterbury during 1819 and only meeting
recreational guidelines for simba sent
of the samples and what is our plane in
conjunction with ich in because it is a
zipper recommendation that a plane for
improvement at this this waterway is
accelerated through the zipper so where
are we worth with that particularly in
light that the William Street Bridge is
designated now as a swimming hole a
swimming spot and with that sort of
water quality where do we go from here
great question Sandra madam chair so yes
we do have WDC have pigeon Connie
control measures planned for the 400 so
pigeons under William Street bridge in
August so it's a problem both the guano
that's built up underneath the bridge
which is quite a mountain for a bridge
contractors to remove and also then to
look at how to control the pigeons so
they don't just move to somewhere nearby
or change the structure of the bridge
they won't just they can't use the
leaders therefore for listing so that we
do know from Environment Canterbury work
fecal sauce trekking work that the
source of the e.coli and the river is
quite highly avian we don't know which
particular species but we can look at
the pigeons to start with and then
obviously this Canada geese it's
probably another high highly likely
culprit we haven't had any discussions
about anything further put bit for bird
control use
yes
it is an excellent move to have both
sees some river projects now within the
agenda of the water committee and I'm
really keen that the work continues the
profile needs to be raised of the work
that's being done and hopefully this
will all happen because essentially this
is a couple of projects under the wider
area our hearted as a framework so
you're very keen that we continue with
the impetus that we have have here and
involve partner Qian and Runa I was as
Chris has already indicated really
pleased to have the meeting with Fred
Brooks and he's undertaken from memory
to have a program about what he can is
actually doing in the carp way as far as
what I control they're out there at the
moment doing poisoning that IV and
talking about what planting program they
have and how we can we can work in with
them so that was very productive and
very keen to keep that content and if in
fact it doesn't as far as the ky4
end and we didn't get up to Kim but that
does follow that we keep we keep the
liaison and the encouragement after
heaven in Bmore not only do the work but
also talk about it to the community so
everybody understands what's going on
and and fred was really good in that um
he he took on board that the type of the
type of maintenance they do for we're up
in the back blocks is not appropriate
for a stretch of urban waterway life the
cowboy and and became too so that was
very productive so happy - because I
said endorse this program right any
other comments yes let it consume you
look just to reiterate that it's
important I think in this committee with
the transfer of what we're doing now one
of the main aims of the rehabilitation
committee from the from the start was to
remind again and every available
opportunity that the stretch of order
that runs through a town is very
different to any other stretch of water
that they have in Canterbury and that
they are responsible for and
unfortunately gets missed by many people
with a Nikken that there is you know
twelve thirteen thousand people that
live on the shores of that river and
it's important that with the transfer of
this that the land and water committee
keep that in front of a kin and keep
reminding that it is not just a place of
normal river where all they do is
control willow and and put riverbanks it
is somewhere where people lives people
live and they need to be reminded of
that often
it's a memo for information on the
essential freshwater package I don't
know
Jeff do you want to come and talk to it
all well well so I wondered whether we
just yes okay in your hands the in PS
and the alias for freshwater management
were put out for public consultation
during 2019 there were seventeen and a
half thousand submissions on on the
essential freshwater package and the
government or the MFA and the Minister
for the environment referred the
submissions to an independent assessment
panel chaired by former Environment
Court Judge David Shepherd and David
Shepards report has been submitted now
to government and they're still
decisions haven't been made so there's a
little bit of smoke and mirrors going on
in terms of the way that MFE are dealing
with this because they've got a
publication called decisions on the
national direction for freshwater well
the decisions haven't been made yet so
all that's happened is that Judge
Shepherd has given his independent
assessment panel report to back to the
minister and the minister is not due to
make a decision on the recommendations
from the independent assessment panel
until July so it's sort of like
decisions when you're not having
decisions and and there's been a lot in
the press about you know these great
announcements and all these sorts of
things but we still haven't seen the
color of the money in terms of what
parts of the independent assessment
panel's reports are going to be
incorporated into the NPS of freshwater
management and the NES for fresh water
so that's at least a month away
questions I have and any of those having
any urgent general business there's
nothing in committee our next meeting is
August the 13th here in person we are so
thank you very much for your attendance
and I declare this meeting closed at
10:40 6 a.m.